presles politique réunion au sommet des
deux candidats ps sur le limousin poitou
charentes aux élections régionales ce
matin à limoges une visite de courtoisie
entre ségolène royal accompagnée de
françois hollande et jean paul denanot
mais pas seulement
à trois jours du second tour il
s'agissait aussi d'évoquer les relations
actuelles et à venir entre les deux
régions
jean-jacques théodore comme d'habitude
ségolène l'a fait attendre un bon quart
d'heure mais comme le parfum de la
victoire rend tout le monde florrick
françois hollande le ligueur parfait de
réflexion et il n'a même rien dit
envoyons sa compagne a posé très
officiellement sa signature à côté de
celle de jean paul denanot au bas d'un
contrat qui les lie tous les deux sur le
plan politique elle a le droit de tout
faire en restant à gauche bien sûr sur
le plan privé
je n'ai pas de noms plus de droit à
exercer car vous connaissez notre
relation donc je la laisse libre de ses
mouvements mais j'ai trouvé bien qu'elle
le soit en compagnie de jean-paul
porteuse d'un beau message de solidarité
entre nos deux régions limousin poitou
charentes car c'est bien en faveur d'une
coopération renforcée entre le limousin
et le poitou charentes que se sont
engagés ce matin ce qui semble devoir
demain présider les deux conseils
régionaux
il s'agit notamment de coordonner les
politiques en matière d'infrastructures
d'emploi d'agriculture et
d'environnement
une démarche pragmatique que ségolène
royal oppose aux promesses démagogiques
de ses adversaires par exemple le fameux
tgv limoges poitiers ressuscité par jean
pierre raffarin et bernadette chirac
c'est pas sérieux ces annonces pré
électorale c'est j'en ai vu aussi parce
qu'il ya des ministres qui sont venues
toutes les semaines en poitou charentes
pour promettre des millions et des
millions d'euros qui n'ont dont ils
n'ont pas le premier d'ailleurs
donc je crois que les électeurs se
rassemblent autour des candidats sérieux
qui qui ont travaillé qui présentent des
projets structure est solide et qu'il se
détourne des promesses farfelues qui
sont l'agitation et de la bulle pas
avant les élections
et si le second tour lors est aussi
favorable que le premier jean paul
denanot et ségolène royal se
retrouveront dès lundi prochain avec
leurs collègues de la région centre
michel sapin dans le village des rôles
aux confins des trois régions à
l'endroit même où il y à un mois du cet
effet mutuellement des promesses de
victoire